well Nevada law requires removal of
decorative grass in the valley by the
end of 2026. the law was signed by
governor sisilak in 2021 due to low
water levels at Lake Mead and our
ongoing drought Mary Jane beliesza joins
us from Desert Shores where this change
is already underway
it's a community where there's already
an abundance of water due to its
beautiful lakes the Desert Shores
Community but now they need to cut back
on the turf according to the Desert
Shores Community website the association
and the Southern Nevada Water Authority
are working together on what they need
to keep or change Margot Quinones has
lived in the Desert Shores Community for
over 20 years Desert Shore is a
community here they just kind of sprung
it on us they did not advise us that it
was coming and that they had received
the Mandate from the city they had
informed us then there wouldn't have
been such an uproar people were very
very upset you get a letter all of a
sudden it says you know is this is your
share it's like what
On The Desert Shores Community website
the association acknowledged this
conversion would mean tough
circumstances for their residents
including a special payment assessment
of sixteen hundred dollars for
single-family homes and eight hundred
dollars for condos I think it's a good
idea everybody should conserve water as
far as Gardens go there's a lot of older
areas here that have humongous amounts
of grass Desert Shores isn't the only
community that needs to follow this
mandate Joel just the CEO of Camco is
working with several homeowner
associations throughout the valley on
this transition the big push right now
is there's there's subsidies available
for for associations I know out in my
area Sun City Anthem is doing a lot of
that taking all that Turf out and
replanting the xeroscape so desert
plants just says with this new standard
it will help replenish all the water
needed despite some pushback from some
homeowners I recommend everybody try and
do it as soon as possible because
because the monies that are available
are are not re they're not replenishing
it so once it's out once it's done it's
done and then you'll have to do it on
your own dime Desert Shores also States
on their website the biggest challenge
during this conversion is to maintain
and improve their Community Mary Jane
beliesza 8 News Now